most people think that they want to
retire as a millionaire but now the
information is coming out if you have a
million dollars when you retire you're
broke you literally can't survive what
do i mean experts are saying that you
should plan on only accessing
3.3 percent of your retirement nest egg
rather than the traditional four percent
but wait what in the world does that
mean if you retire with a million
dollars that leaves you with less than
two thousand eight hundred dollars a
month to spend that's right if you get
to retirement age you have a million
dollars in your account according to
their estimates that would only leave
you about 2800 a month to actually live
on the average age of retirement is 62.
and so when do people plan on retiring
well if you are between the ages of 25
and 40. you plan to retire at an average
age of 59. you're very optimistic i'm
going to be rich and i will retire
before i'm 60. if you are between 41 and
56 you say ah it might take me an extra
year or so i'm gonna retire at 60. but
if you're between the ages of 57 to 75
you plan to retire at an average age of
68. literally you are right there and
you know you're not gonna make it to
retirement by 60. the median retirement
savings by age according to the
transamerica center for retirement
studies is in their 20s you only have 16
000 in your 30s you have 45 000 if
you're in your 40s you have 63 000 in
retirement savings if you're in your 50s
you have 117 000 and unfortunately the
average or the median retirement savings
for people in their 60s is 172 000
now go back and remember if you have a
million dollars you get to spend 2 800
per month according to the expert
estimations but if you only have about
20
of that guess what my friends that means
that you get approximately five to six
hundred dollars per month to spend if
you only have 172 172 000
in your retirement savings in your 60s
that's just about 500 to 600 per month
that you have to spend so how much do i
need to save for retirement well
according to the federal reserve s c f
data if you are 18 to 24 you should be
putting 4 745
away for retirement and if you get into
your 40s now you need 100 grand if
you're in 65 to 69 they're saying that
you only need somewhere in the 200 000
so ages 55 to 69 the federal reserve scf
data 223 000 to 200 000
is what they suggest now of course as we
just talked about that doesn't leave you
nearly a lot of money to actually spend
on a monthly basis
and so
if you have a million dollars at
retirement this means an individual
would have 583 less a month to spend
while retired what do we mean well they
used to tell you that if you have a
million dollars saved you should spend
four percent a month of your money so
million dollars you withdraw four
percent your monthly income is three
thousand three hundred and thirty three
dollars and your annual income is forty
thousand dollars that is how they used
to think about it but now all of a
sudden they said maybe you shouldn't
actually withdraw four percent and they
dropped it to three point three percent
so your million dollars 3.3
spent per month means that your monthly
income is actually only 2 700
and your annual income is 33 000
now for those of you that are sitting at
home most of you are probably not
excited about retiring on 33 000 a year
or 40 000 a year and so if you just back
into the math you're gonna need more
than a million dollars in your
retirement savings when you go to retire
that means if you're young get to work
that means if you're older you either
have to take risk or you have to figure
out passive income to go ahead and
supplement your retirement savings those
are the only two paths to actually
having a material amount of monthly
income to live on now of course people
have been doing this for decades you can
do it on these smaller amounts of money
but i think most people they aspire
whether they get there or not to be able
to actually do it with larger sums of
money and so if you want more than 40
000 a year to live off of in retirement
then you're gonna need more than a
million dollars in that retirement
savings and so ultimately i think
there's a lot of people with big dreams
but they're not necessarily doing the
work to get there today john when you
see these numbers is this just an
indication that most people are
significantly behind where they're gonna
have to be at retirement or is this
something that is just uh it sounds good
to talk about having a million dollars
in retirement savings but ultimately uh
this is just math and you can switch
these numbers in an analysis doesn't
matter uh really it's concerning to me
that an american has 172 thousand
dollars uh for retirement when they
retire in their 60s when the average
retirement is 62. it is very concerning
that people are not set up financially
to be able to retire and it also speaks
to kind of the debasement and the value
of the us dollar and how
a million dollars really isn't what it
used to be and people used to aspire to
have that and now it's almost like a
baseline that you need to have that at a
certain point in life just be able to be
able to retire comfortably well the
interesting part too is when you look at
the data not only uh does a million
dollars not get you what it used to
based on inflation of all these other
things but the the average person thinks
they're going to retire sooner right so
when you look at what we have here the
baby boomers said that they want to
retire at an average age of 68
generation x was age 60 they want to
retire and generation y was 59 i'm sure
generation z is even lower and all that
right so like when you really start to
think about it people are opting for uh
more time more freedom or uh higher
quality of life and they want to retire
earlier than previous generations had
thought was possible mix that with the
with the inability to do that with the
amount of capital that they're currently
saving and you're going to need a higher
amount and all this stuff and it makes
it even worse so i think that people are
in for a real wake-up call when it comes
to the amount of money that's actually
needed for retirement and maybe that
number trends up right maybe when you're
25 years old you say hey i'm going to
retire at age 50. and then you realize
when you get older maybe i don't have
enough money maybe it's 60 and maybe it
keeps going up or whatever but
ultimately i think people would be
shocked to know how much you actually
need based on kind of when you plan on
retiring how much you spend per month
and then you don't have the ability to
fluctuate off of that if you don't have
additional income or investments that
are producing cash flow off of that so i
think that it's a uh a fair point to
look at and a fair point for people to
be concerned about but ultimately it all
depends on personal circumstances and
what you plan on doing in retirement if
you plan on earning income still what
age you plan to retire at if you have
investments and all these other things
but yeah ultimately i i think it's
probably a little bit concerning that a
million dollars does not get get it
would get you what it used to when it
comes to retirement the other piece of
the retirement game that seems to always
go uh completely undiscussed
is when you have the
um when you have like the withdrawal
right obviously you're going to have to
be able to outpace that withdrawal uh on
a on an annual basis but the second
thing is that it doesn't have to just be
what are my retirement savings and oh
let me you know
hope that the government ends up paying
me some money instead what ends up
happening i think is that if you're
really smart you also are going to end
up with passive income as well whether
that is uh interest bearing accounts or
real estate or something like that so if
you're a young person that's really what
you have to focus on is you've got to
focus on how the hell can we go ahead
and get some sort of passive income so
that i can live off that uh forever and
one of the things that i always tell
young people is a a really important
thing in their financial journey is
figure out what your monthly expenses
are so let's just say i'll pick an easy
name let's say you spend three thousand
dollars a month that's between rent food
expenses the whole nine yards spend
three thousand dollars set a goal for
three times that nine to ten thousand
dollars right and pick that number and
say can i get to the point where i am
earning nine to ten thousand dollars a
month in passive income whether that is
from real estate interest paying
accounts or whatever and most people
won't get there but guess what if you
get to five or six thousand dollars
early on well that covers your monthly
expenses and now if you keep your job
then you basically take that income and
that ends up being uh kind of
supplemental right a lot of like
professional athletes they started to
figure out wait a second i'm not gonna
touch my uh contract so i get paid you
know five million dollars a year from
the team and i also have a bunch of
marketing deals i'm gonna live off the
marketing money i'm never gonna touch
the
actual uh contract money and so same
thing here is if you could get to the
point where your passive income you say
i'm gonna live off my passive income i'm
not gonna touch the money i make at work
or vice versa and that's ultimately
where people start to really get to kind
of like true financial freedom is when
they have the passive income that is
able to eclipse what their monthly
expenses are in some cases they even get
it to the where it actually eclipse what
they make at work absolutely you made a
great point about setting your goals so
high that even if you fail you're still
higher than you would be originally so
if you set a goal of ten thousand
dollars a month in passive income and
you only get to 50 of that or 5 000 a
month you still have that 5 000 a month
in passive income which i think is key
for a lot of people so set your goals
high